6 42 here on a monday morning it's a big
morning across the valley alex as more
high school kids go back to class i know
that includes high school seniors a lot
of them are excited to get back
and monica's joining us this morning
with some really important things to
remember hey monica
hey guys uh happy monday to you and
happy monday to you folks at 6 42 right
now
we are talking vaccines on this mondays
with monica i know it's been
overwhelming for you because as a parent
myself it's been overwhelming for us and
we've been trying to stay on top of it
so i hope this interview
helps you out we are joined this morning
with dr robbie zia he is a local
pediatrician from
desert valley pediatrics and he's here
to kind of work it all out dr zia thank
you so much for joining us how you doing
i'm good thank you how are you good
morning oh doing real good let's get
right into it because the kids are back
to school and one of the things that
i know a lot of us are worried about are
the regular vaccines i'm talking about
the mmr the dtap and all of that so
talk about the age groups that require
vaccines under normal
circumstances absolutely so
as you see from this pandemic we have
realized the importance of the
vaccinations
society has been on pause and millions
of lives have been lost
uh with that said uh there are 14
vaccine preventable
illnesses and it's very important that
our parents go out there and get these
vaccinations
the vaccine itself has have eradicated
almost all of these diseases and none of
these vaccines are necessarily a one-hit
wonder
you actually have to complete the course
and
up unt for you to get the full immunity
with that said um the vaccinations
itself
bulk of the vaccinations are completed
before two years of age followed
by boosters that are given between four
to six and eleven years of age
okay and um yeah you could get the
entire list of vaccinations that's out
there on cdc
and that's exactly what we recommend and
doctor
how does the covet vaccine fit into into
this schedule
or how will it fit moving forward into
the regular schedule for vaccines with
children
um as you know um cov19 vaccine still
uh it's in the clinical trials so we are
not exactly sure
where it will fall with the vaccination
schedule
you know as vaccines go dr zia you
should only get
you know vaccinated once with the
schedule like you just pointed out
do you think there's enough research
that confirms that covet 19 the vaccine
is a once-in-a-lifetime vaccine or is
that another one where we just don't
know yet
uh it's just another one that
unfortunately would not we do not know
i'm not sure if it will be like the flu
vaccine considering there are
uh different variants of the covet 19
vaccine so time will tell and we just
have to wait for the clinical trials
released by all these pharmaceutical
companies before we could move forward
yeah now i know this is kind of putting
you on the spot but you're a doctor i
know you get this question on a regular
basis especially now
you know parents have had a fear um for
years now you've heard about
you know the mmr being associated with
autism i have a nephew
who is autistic that was a concern for
my sister
so you throw in the covet 19 vaccine
into that mix parents fears are already
through the roof
how do you calm everybody down
make sure that parents are bringing the
kids in for the vaccines
in spite of the pandemic
so uh it's very important for parents to
realize
unfortunately this pandemic itself
wasn't evidence
the importance of vaccinations so many
lives have been lost
there are these diseases that the
vaccines have uh come out in the past
that have mostly eradicated these
diseases so other side out of mind
so with that said i would uh suggest
when it comes down to the covert 19
vaccine
it's very important for the parents to
consult with their own pediatrician
regarding their child's past medical
history
before they come to a conclusion to give
the kobit-19 vaccine or not
yeah and this is ali suggests at this
point it's very important
parents do consult with their
pediatrician regarding the kobe 19
vaccine
okay and you know again i'm putting you
on the spot here but the news is
unfolding on a daily basis you're
hearing about
the astrazeneca there are questions
about that over in europe they had some
issues
but kids are going back to school today
um if you had to make the decision in in
light of everything you know
as a doctor as a specialist would you
allow your kids to go back to school
absolutely and with that said my uh
daughter is five and a half years old
and she has been attending school since
august
and the precautions that the school are
taking are amazing
and as a pediatrician in the community
i'll tell you i
rarely have heard of any outbreak within
the community because of covid
in the school this they're going above
and beyond making sure
they're keeping our children and our
future protected i was hoping you were
going to be able to say that because i
know that's a you know that's a loaded
question
especially now a lot of people are very
sensitive about this i was watching
60 minutes last night and it was a it
was a very compelling story that
a superintendent in marietta georgia
told about the kids going back
some kids on the sports team contracted
the virus but for the most part
the kids were excited to get back in so
doctor if folks have questions for you
how can they reach out to you
um they could absolutely reach out to
our office um
it's uh 702-260-4525 and
i'd love to answer any questions and
definitely i would love to meet them if
needed absolutely doctor robbie zia
thank you so much from desert valley
pediatrics
folks check them out online desert
valleypediatricslv.com we appreciate it
and hope your little one has a great day
in school today doc thank you
thank you absolutely you have a good day
nice to meet you all right and you too
so folks there you have it i hope that
that helps you out and we'll do our best
to make sure that we continue to bring
you more information
as it becomes available don't forget
check me out on my mlj show facebook
live tonight at 7 p.m we'll replay this
interview for you as well
keeping you posted on everything because
the news is changing
on a daily basis and you're a parent so
uh nate you know how this feels when you
have to let your kid go
into you know an area where you're not
really sure about absolutely really
great information this morning monica
thank you so much for that interview
yeah absolutely